[Music]
in not allowed news
ma submitted by lovely Pringle favorite
Pringle flavor go already general sour
cream nice sour cream shower cream line
Pizza Pizza ones actually pretty good
stop and vinegar salt vinegar except if
something good I made that one you know
I actually don't like Pringles I think
they might be very interesting I like
the kettle the kettle that's a different
world that's a different world though
Pringles taste like the powdered mashed
potato yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
same world another person was kicked off
a flight for bringing an unauthorized
emotional support animal on board I saw
this I thought someone got kicked off
for bringing a box of [ __ ] Pringles
and it went bad like a gun and then
they're like oh once you pop you can't
stop
I like doing duck lips with them when I
was a kid those were the perfect chips
to eat in class too because it melts
when you put it at the roof of your
[ __ ] [ __ ] tongue up against it
later and they're the perfect for
putting in backpacks because your books
don't crush the chip cycle we were all
sponsored you think I do just so mad cuz
I was his teacher name is Salman said
she would get mad at us for eating [ __ ]
but this [ __ ] would eat candy
throughout the whole [ __ ] class what
if she had stank breath and she was
doing you a favor
no it's straight-up candy issues like
400 pounds yeah my brother used to be
her teacher assistant and then he took
like a snicker oh he banged her for sure
I showed you a picture he took a snicker
from her like special drawer and mind
you there's like 70 Snickers in there
and she knew what was missing too what
and she would not let it go until
somebody came out who took the snicker
no way
your brother didn't even come out no
humans like that theme from Matilda with
the [ __ ] chocolate cake I knew Zima
Tommy Mottola
I've seen it the chocolate cake part so
do you miss Thomasin be sure had your
back oh yeah I was just thinking about I
forgot how could you have not seen
Matilda think about demon I forgot that
teacher lady
who watch Matilda Oh Miss Trunchbull
tranche of all Darius tangible yes miss
Transpo the young daughter who mrs.
doubtfire play but Tilda yes yes okay I
didn't see it but I know I see you go
with the power and the thumb that mmm
Danny DeVito was the dad maybe I did you
know I never watched me tell her oh my
god tell you like every single line a
time limit I watched bloodsport because
of that movie I I wanted beautiful movie
you've ever seen as a kid dude that's so
sad it's like the most violent you see
bloodsport
uncut the guy got kicked in his leg and
his knee came out of the socket and
ripped through the skin yeah it's on
this [ __ ] anyway
your mom didn't let you watch Goonies
but your mom let you watch blood let's
go [ __ ] dude cause she's like all comfo
that's a good movie okay okay Peter Pan
hell no so this story here is about an
emotional squirrel is emotional support
squirrel that's tight yeah I know I knew
you would good night so cute that's
Ellie eat I should think so big and they
start in their cheeks and a fence I
didn't know squirrel tails are so fluffy
and they just wanted squirrels aren't
native to us they were brought over they
were there from where like parks so they
were cute and they were brought as
entertainment for parts and now they're
just here now I don't know what I don't
[ __ ] know but they were literally
brought for our entertainment to put
into parks and they just infest
entertain the [ __ ] out of you and I see
them yeah but those are my dogs aren't
they pairs consider consider passed
somewhere yeah
a little [ __ ] yeah so this woman she
was born this tick this took place in
Orlando they were trying to go to
relieve Cincinnati and no Cleveland they
were trying to go to Cleveland and she
snuck in this squirrel
Oh wolf it's a sneak it's not that nice
she did put in her ticket or whatever
that she had an emotional support animal
was she didn't specify what kind of
animal and rodents are not allowed on so
she [ __ ] up yeah along with reptiles
insects hedge hothead hedgehogs he can't
be a rabbit's sugar gliders yeah I had
no idea to accost sugar glider you know
where she [ __ ] up I bet you that
squirrel didn't have overall on had
overalls on he just made him a hillbilly
though no I like Curious George like
overalls and in a hat with a spinny
thing if the if the squirrel know what I
thought it was never mind if the
squirrel had a little squirrel hat and
then overalls and in a [ __ ] jacket
that said emotional support like the
doggy vet or it is okay if I had a sugar
glider I how would you keep a sugar
glider like what would you put it in a
cage I think you're not winning your
house then let it fly yeah yeah like
have like but it'll [ __ ] everywhere I
mean yeah I gotta clean it maybe
probably I don't know squirrel behavior
because if you keep it in a cage I feel
really sad yeah is that cage was like a
whole side of the wall and there was k2
[ __ ] but it could be invasive that's why
it's a it's illegal in some states
because it could be an invasive species
so some of its like illegal same with um
ferrets and [ __ ] like that too you know
a lot of places aren't allowing
emotional support animals anymore just
people yeah people are people are loop
holding it and make you know making them
seem like there's service animals and
they are clearly not service animals
white people and [ __ ] yeah because
they're not certified by the ABA the the
service animals are what's 88 American
disability yeah
so the the people that are doing that
that's shame on them they should not be
trying to stretch emotional support
vehicle yeah they should not be you know
I mean even though meatloaf also has a
red vest this woman by bringing in her
squirrel she they ended up happy so she
refused to leave once they realized I
she had a squirrel cause she had any one
of those like pet carrier things and so
they had to do plane the entire plane in
order to get her out finally got her out
someone took a video of her leaving here
we go
[Music]
so she did is like she said you stupid
[ __ ] she was flipping them off and
then people started cheering because she
was leaving but she thought they were
cheering because she was flipping them
off so then she goes thank you huh you
know what somebody I read an article I
read an article it is so funny this is
just this is why you should be careful
about media and how like biased it is
cuz the other one that I read said that
she registered everything and the
airline [ __ ] up and it was their fault
so she was the one that was trying to
get a loophole and she knew that you
couldn't bring rodents in well now not
even that but that's that's what stated
and she didn't state what animal it was
so in both cases one is saying she
didn't register one is saying that she
did I said that she did register that
she had an emotional support animal but
she didn't specify what I see I got yeah
thing that I saw was trying to make her
look like she was a hero like she was
the one that was wronged so that's what
I'm saying like it's just so media so
[ __ ] up sometimes dude like well
depends on who's writing it yeah because
the person that that does have a [ __ ]
emotional support Mouse that plays
basketball or some [ __ ] you know like
they want to go on the plane with it
she's playing like oh I'm gonna [ __ ]
write about this and it she's on her
side yeah it's so interesting then
because that makes way more sense yeah
yeah because the other one I saw it I
was like there's something off about
this you know and so there it is you did
the research for me thank you
is it [ __ ] up to say that if you need
an emotional support pet to fly that
don't [ __ ] fly yeah all the way okay
yeah because what if there's like a
family emergency you have to get across
the country somehow quickly you should
fly and then like you need that pet for
support emotion yo I saw this yesterday
I was jogging and then I saw a pitbull
that was so [ __ ] well-trained every
time a person walks by people will stop
and sit and then when person goes by it
stands back up and starts doing this
thing so I thought it was just
coincidence but somebody walked by them
that she-demon commanded ah they got
stopped and sat waited and then it got
up when he left it when I jog when I was
jogging up to it stopped again any set
can't walk that dog in Japan
sitting everywhere I was so surprised
how well-trained that [ __ ] dog was
man it was amazing didn't even [ __ ]
look at me once yeah I'd be devastated
if you didn't look at me once much time
to like do that with your dog like gotta
be there 24/7 cuz like they're always
just I actually really really really
really loved pit bulls I just don't like
the size of their Dookie it's just so
[ __ ] pimples too they're buff they're
could you could slap them and they think
it's super fun you could wrestle them I
just the dukey's are literally this size
dude it's huge man I just don't hate
picking up heavy Dookie man that's why I
like small dogs just let my Shepard Duke
is here Duke he's a [ __ ] huge yeah I
literally have used two hands it was
it's like wild I hate that [ __ ] pony
I've seen meatloaf take a full [ __ ] at
once so usually no [ __ ] shits alike
shits are like this right no I mean it
goes like this and it slowly comes out
might be giving that crouched stance and
the [ __ ] thing comes out of the bow
I've seen me love go [ __ ] like a pack
of hot dogs I'm like what the it didn't
even get pushed out that [ __ ] was crazy
that's crazy
that's how horses [ __ ] no they still
push it out cuz it's so like yeah cuz
they'll be on I like walking in I'm like
babe did you see that I wouldn't know
she was excited like I just I don't want
a big though I don't want to clean a big
Dookie grind up save your family ever
tell you like if you ever watch a dog -
[ __ ] the bump oh no not that I like you
if you stare at them then they have a
hard time pooping Oh enough reviews like
you'll get it in your eyes I love it
when dogs poop though cuz they look so
stupid
and then they stare at you yeah yeah I
feel wrong looking at him you know what
I read why they do that right yeah so
being in that position when you're
[ __ ] you could get attacked and
that's the most vulnerable time so they
they had they kind of look
their owner for support to make sure
that you're there or they're looking out
for like oh [ __ ] what y'all thought it
was weird these [ __ ] that dude
they start trembling did you see that
okay my dogs look dead straight into my
soul when that's it the business super
uncomfortable ugh do you like this do
you like looking at me thinking [ __ ] do
you like this trick just [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]